the early development of christianity is
one of the most fascinating subjects
there is in my opinion there is so much
diversity mysterious ancient texts that
show up every now and then to shed new
light on something we didn't know before
not to mention that it allows us to
trace the gradual development of what is
today the largest religion in the world
in the diversity of movements based on
the teachings of jesus of nazareth some
strayed very far from his jewish roots
in their doctrines such as the
various groups that we now call the
gnostics while others were very much
still part of the jewish religion and
considered his message to be within the
bounds of judaism and the most famous of
these jewish christian groups is
probably the mysterious and fascinating
ebionites
[Laughter]
[Applause]
jesus of nazareth was jewish few
scholars or people generally today would
deny this his life and teachings need to
be understood through that lens and
taking the jewish context of his
environment into consideration now that
doesn't mean that he couldn't have
taught a message that somehow broke with
the traditional jewish religion or
indeed that his later followers did in
terms of the latter they actually
definitely did eventually but things are
also a lot more complicated than this
the earliest centuries of christianity
can be a hard topic to get a hold of
because it consists of so much diversity
and variation
indeed before something like an
orthodoxy was established in the
different church councils there were
many christianities all vying to
represent the true teachings of jesus as
we've explored in earlier episodes on
related topics we should avoid the
anachronistic view that there was an
orthodoxy from the beginning and that
various sects diverged from this
orthodoxy the variety of early
christianity was a lot more complex and
chaotic than this in any case the
various ways that jesus's message was
interpreted and put into practice could
differ dramatically and there were
debates about basically every
conceivable point of belief
some of these debates were eventually
formally discussed in the famous church
councils which tackled questions like
the nature of jesus who was he in
relation to god what was the
relationship between his divine and
human natures how does the trinity work
etc outside of these councils which took
place in a context where certain tenets
of the religion had already started to
be agreed upon the debates could be even
broader
was there even a trinity at all and was
jesus even god or simply a human messiah
we don't have time to go through all the
debates and discussions that were
floating around in the earliest periods
of christianity in this episode but this
is the general outlook that needs to be
kept in mind there were many different
christianities that could look very
different from each other
in an earlier episode we explore the
teachings of the gnostics who often
denied jesus's human nature altogether
and rejected much of the hebrew bible or
old testament by claiming that the god
of the israelites was a false ignorant
god distinct from the true god that had
sent jesus
this is thus an example of a group that
definitely distinguished themselves from
the religion of judaism and this was in
fact another one of the most significant
early debates
what is the relationship between
christianity broadly defined as the
movement and teachings of jesus and the
jewish faith many of us know that the
separation of christianity into its own
religion was a gradual one and as we
said in the beginning few would deny
that jesus himself was a jew who lived
and preached to jews in a jewish
environment but in the early period this
question seems to have been a great
point of contention in the gospel of
matthew jesus famously said quote do not
think that i have come to abolish the
law or the prophets i have not come to
abolish them but to fulfill them
this verse as well as in general the
relationship between jesus's teachings
and the jewish law has been interpreted
by later christians in various ways that
fit with the idea of religious
distinctness between the two religions
but in the earliest periods this seems
to have been quite a point of serious
debate after jesus death it seems that
his community of followers were based in
jerusalem and led by his brother james
as well as the apostle peter and the
perspective of these leaders appeared to
have been one where the jewish law was
still kept and that jesus's life
teachings and death was seen in a jewish
light as being still essentially part of
this religion
in other words it was a jewish movement
led by jews who had been close with
jesus
this version of events while neglected
by some seems to be corroborated in the
new testament as the letters of paul
make reference to a disagreement that he
had with the leaders in jerusalem on
whether gentile converts needed to get
circumcised and observe the jewish law
paul of course is a central figure in
the early spread and formation of
christianity he had been a prominent
jewish persecutor of proto-christians
before converting after a miraculous
encounter with thee by then deceased
christ while on the road to damascus he
had never met jesus in the flesh but
became very important for the conveying
and spreading of his message and in this
process of proselytizing that is
converting people in the regions of the
roman empire both jews and gentiles he
argued that those who accepted the
message of christ did not have to follow
the jewish law jesus life and
resurrection represented a new covenant
that broke with the old law and thus
offered a new identity but the leaders
in jerusalem presumably james and peter
seem to have disagreed instead arguing
that non-jewish converts must indeed get
circumcised observe the sabbath and
follow the jewish law in general this
tension also seems to have manifested in
the larger proto-christian community at
the time some groups following the
opinions of james while others being
more in line with paul's more universal
perspective as we all know it was paul's
perspective that eventually won the day
and became part of christian orthodoxy
indeed as one of its most central
doctrines but this is a very significant
aspect of the early jesus movement that
helps us to get some perspective on how
a religion develops as well as the
diversity that existed in the early
christian community and indeed it also
gives us a background to understand the
main topic of this video the ebionites
which was a group that definitely
disagreed with paul and who often seems
to have considered james who was jesus's
brother and the early leader in
jerusalem as one of their central
figures and inspirations
so who were the ebionites well basically
they were a group of jewish followers of
jesus who believed that he was the
messiah but that following him and his
message meant that you had to be jewish
and all that that entails the ibanites
were not the only jewish christians at
the time but are probably the most
famous there's another term called the
nazarenes which was used
at this time to refer to a more broad
category of jewish christians it appears
but the ebu knights are probably the
most famous group or perhaps groups
that fall under this category so what do
we know about them
sadly not much at all as is usually the
case with movements in early
christianity that didn't become orthodox
we don't have much to go on
the ebiu knights haven't survived the
events of history at least not in a
direct way so we can't ask them about
their beliefs and we don't have the
luxury of something like a naghamadi
library which allowed us first-hand
access to text by other other christian
groups like the gnostics in other words
no texts or writings by the ibinites
themselves survive for us to study so we
have to rely exclusively on accounts by
horeseologists or writers at the time
who were critical of this group we can
only know about them through the
writings of their enemies as it were
writers like irenaeus who called them
judaizers and heretics who were quote
stubbornly clinging to the law so it
goes without saying that all of this
information should of course be taken
with a grain of salt but what we do get
is fascinating the name ibinites is
uncertain in itself but the christian
father origin of alexandria writes that
the name comes from the hebrew word
ebion which means poor and this perhaps
speaks to the ascetic tendencies of this
group
to the ebionites jesus was central and
very important of course but he had not
established a new religion per se
instead jesus was the human jewish
messiah sent by god to fulfill the
earlier jewish scriptures jesus was not
god he didn't exist before creation nor
was he born miraculously of a virgin he
was a human being who followed the
jewish law to such a perfect extent and
lived such a pious life that he was
chosen or adopted by god to be his son
not necessarily in the literal way
understood by christian orthodoxy but as
a more traditional jewish title as son
in the sense of being chosen for a
special mission by god in the words of
the scholar board airman quote to
express the matter more fully the
ebionites believed that jesus was a real
flesh and blood human like the rest of
us born as the eldest son of the sexual
union of his parents joseph and mary
what set jesus apart from all other
people was that he kept god's law
perfectly and so was the most righteous
man on earth as such god chose him to be
his son and assigned to him a special
mission to sacrifice himself for the
sake of others
jesus then went to the cross not as a
punishment for his own sins but for the
sins of the world a perfect sacrifice
and fulfillment of all god's promises to
his people the jews in the holy
scriptures as a sign of his acceptance
of jesus sacrifice god then raised jesus
from the dead and exalted him to heaven
this also meant as you can tell that
jesus remains much more connected to
traditional judaism and the ebinites saw
themselves as jews while certain jewish
practices were modified as we will see
they held that it was still the jews
that were the chosen people and that it
was the jewish religion that jesus had
preached and fulfilled and then
maintained by his brother james through
the jerusalem church the ebu nets thus
maintain the jewish law as central to
salvation so to say
they were circumcised kept a kosher diet
observed the sabbath and all other
features of the jewish law there were
however certain ways in which they would
differ from the judaism that had been
practiced prior to the life of jesus the
sacrifice that jesus made on the cross
had an effect on the law and this seems
to have led the ebonites to completely
reject the ritual sacrifice that had
been common in the temple not only this
but the ibonites are also famous for
going even further by being vegetarians
they didn't consume any meat and
consider this to have been the practice
and message of jesus himself as well as
john the baptist so what was all of this
based on obviously the ebu nuts believe
themselves to be following the true
message of jesus and that all their
teachings came directly from him in
terms of scripture the primary source
was the hebrew bible or old testament
which is natural given the fact that
they were jews who put an emphasis on
the jewish law but they seem to have
accepted some newer scriptures as well
which recounted the more recent events
involving jesus and his mission some
sources suggest that they would have
used a version of the gospel of matthew
that was somewhat different from the one
that we have in the biblical canon
they're probably excluding parts that
run counter to eb not views of jesus
this text might have been in aramaic
either originally or translated from an
original greek in the accounts of a
later church father epiphanius it is
claimed that there was also a gospel of
the ebionites which appears to have been
a kind of harmonization between the
gospels of matthew mark and luke
epiphanius actually includes a few
quotes from this lost text which means
that it is the only actual direct quotes
possibly that we have from an eb united
source and these quotes show that this
supposed gospel of the ibeonites
differed in some significant ways from
the gospels as we have them it is for
example here that the supposed
vegetarianism of jesus and john the
baptist are put forth by having slightly
different letters certain words that are
just slightly different which gives them
a new meaning in the greek language thus
allowing for an interpretation that
jesus and john the baptist taught
vegetarianism in any case aside from
these features there are a few ideas and
practices that the ib nights seem to
have been associated with but which is
hard to confirm with certainty given the
nature of our sources as the name
suggests the ibonites may have seen
poverty as a virtue as jesus certainly
can be interpreted as having taught and
they seemed to have lived a rather
ascetical and austere life they revered
jerusalem as a particularly holy city
and turned towards it during prayer
epiphanius also claims that the
iberonets practice a type of ritual
bathing on a regular basis similar
perhaps to groups like the essenes
whatever is true of this group it seems
that they didn't survive for all that
long especially after a christian
orthodoxy was established over time we
do however have some fascinating
indications that the eb knights or
perhaps at least groups related to the
ib nights survived in small clusters or
groups spread out around the middle east
for many centuries later some later
sources seem to indicate that the
evianites may have had a presence in
arabia which of course leads to
fascinating questions regarding its
possible influence on the emergence of
islam which holds a very similar view of
jesus as a human prophet indeed even
after this event we have accounts by
various muslim writers that might
indicate that ebonite communities
existed later in history than often
assumed the muatasali theologian
al-qaeda abdul-jabbar recounts an
encounter with a group that might be
identified with the ibranites around the
turn of the first millennium and even
later still the scholar muhammad
al-sharasthani describes a group in the
hijas which is in western arabia that
followed the jewish law but accepted
jesus as a prophetic figure which
suggests to us who this might be
referring to so while they aren't around
today and didn't survive as more than a
marginal group beyond the very earliest
stages of the development of
christianity they still serve as a very
interesting and fascinating example of
the diversity of early christianity they
represent a perspective on the life and
teachings of jesus that emphasizes his
jewish identity and the importance of
following the jewish law christianity
not as a new religion but as a shift an
important turning point within the
already existing tradition of judaism as
such they stand at the very opposite end
of the spectrum to the more famous
gnostics and other related groups they
can point us to the fact that jesus and
his teachings were interpreted in many
different ways by different people in
the early period perhaps even more so
than today and that the relationship
between christianity and judaism was a
hot topic of discussion even to the most
immediate followers of the nazarene
preacher
the ibu nights chased their lineage to
that interesting early leader of the
first church in jerusalem james the just
who is often claimed to be jesus's very
brother and rejected people like paul
and his supporters as heretics and
apostates all this naturally leads to
many what-ifs that we can speculate on
for eternity but we are going to leave
it there for this episode i hope this
was an interesting look into the most
famous of the jewish christian groups in
antiquity and that you are as excited as
i am to continue exploring the early
period of christianity and the jesus
movement in future episodes
thank you everyone for watching thank
you to all of my patrons of course who
support this channel and make
everything turn make all this possible
thank you again so much
feel free to leave a comment and like
the video and i will see you next time
[Music]
you